I knew I couldn't say goodbye to the
woman that I that I was with me in
Monday's bachelor finale will see Ben
Higgins choose between two women Lauren
B and Jojo and he made a bachelor
history by saying I love you to them
both
I got Ben's thoughts on what we can
expect from the big night
not her too
yes an appeaser we saw what looks like a
really tough conversation on a bathroom
floor
what can you tell us about that well
that was I think a solid attempt of
trying to get away from cameras boots
you forget to they're always somewhere
microphones are everywhere I think it
just wasn't needed to be a little
private and so that was what felt right
but you know and what about your mom's
comment that we saw in the tease to know
that Ben could be in love with two women
it's really disturbing to me I don't
know that was a rough tough wording I
don't know maybe maybe there's some love
base behind that but you know off the
front it's a little little aggressive
thanks mom I'm trying over here yeah
really appreciate it I love two women
but now I'm happily in love with one and
that's gonna stay that way for the rest
of my life and it took me thinking about
who I couldn't say goodbye to for the
rest of my life to really make that
decision and it was her we put her
through hell and back sometimes but
she's never ceased to love me and
support me through it and that's why
we're seeing here today and I have I'm
so excited